كنت تعتقد أنك قد طهيت للتو
طبق الباييلا الأصلي ولكن
كن حذرًا لأنه مع ظهور المنشفة
، قيل ذات مرة إذا كنت ستضع
المكونات الخاطئة في الباييلا التقليدية
مثل الأفوكادو أو الكوريزو ، فسيظهر
من هو الوصي على الإنترنت  من بين
جميع أطباق الباييلا التقليدية ،
يعد ويكي باييلا
أحد مؤسسي ويكيبيديا ،
وهي منصة على الإنترنت مخصصة للحفاظ
على طبق الباييلا
متوافقًا مع جذوره الفالنسية في
[الموسيقى]
وكان هذا هو الحال بالتأكيد في عام 2013.
ملتزم في
كل مكان باستخدام الأشجار في
المطاعم كان من خلال
السقف وأعني أن بعض الناس اعتقدوا أن الأرز
اختياري ، تعال ،
للدفاع عن سلامة الطبق ،
حصل رجلنا هنا على صديقين ،
وبحثوا معًا عن المكونات المشروعة
للمكونات
aceta
إذا كنت "  إعادة التساؤل عما إذا كان يمكنك استخدام
المأكولات البحرية ، نعم يمكنك ذلك
ولكن هناك بعض القواعد
[موسيقى]
تمت مشاركة هذين المكونين في
جميع أنحاء العالم على موقع الويب
ويكيبيديا للمطاعم و  طهاة منزليون
للدراسة
ولكن هذه المهمة كانت أكثر بكثير من مجرد
إصلاح الباييلا ، بل كانت تتعلق أيضًا
بالاحتفال بتلك المطاعم التي حصلت على أفضل المطاعم الموجودة
بالمنصة بالفعل والتي يبلغ عددها 350
مطعمًا وأقامت مجتمعًا عالميًا
يضم ما يصل إلى ألف شخص ، وأعني
أنها ساعدت في إعادة تصميم دافع
لا تتذكر الرموز التعبيرية اللحوم والأسماك معًا
ولا تحتوي
البازلاء على أفضل بكثير
[موسيقى]